organizing professional patrols this is
an interesting combat
concept some commanders have gone so far
as to organize permanent patrol groups
whose principal function is to furnish
personnel for battle missions the
officers selected for these groups are
volunteers the most aggressive tough and
rugged officers in the unit
they are permitted to select from the
unit men who possess the same
qualities after a period of intensive
training and scouting patrolling battle
drill
and physical hardening the patrol group
is attached to the unit
headquarters from which it receives its
mission so he's talking look you can
make a little element that's
made of your best guys fatigue and
strain endured by battle patrols make it
impracticable to assign them more than
one major mission every two or three
days upon completion of a mission the
men should be moved
to a rear location fed rested and
prepared for the next
what i what i say is interesting about
this is what do you have
in your company that's a duty
or a mission or a task that maybe it's
such of such importance that you put
together a little hit team
and they get good at it and they do it
all the time and you give them the
support you give them the training
that's a very sensible thing to think
about now it doesn't mean you have to
exclude everybody else because i can
have a hit team of four people that do
uh presentations to clients it doesn't
mean i i send two other guys you know
occasionally i throw this guy i throw
this guy so other people learn
and maybe they spend some time in the
hit team but it's an
interesting concept and a good one to
make someone a professional at that
particular
part of the duty i mean you're a
football player that's like what
football is right special teams
essentially
right yeah yeah i mean it didn't used to
be that way
you used to be like hey we're gonna play
football everybody's playing yeah we're
just playing football yeah
now it's like i'm only going out with
this place happening
that's an interesting way to look at it
yeah only when this place happened yeah
i mean there's some people that only
play one play yeah
kicker kicker kicker uh wedge breaker
something well
that can be kind of versatile um yeah
you're right specialty
bro there was this guy actually he was a
wide receiver but
what the heck was his name he played at
uh trade he
and he was just well he was a wide
receiver for sure and he did some things
or whatever but
it was marginal compared to what his
specialty was
was blocking field goals and punts he
was on the outside because he could run
real fast
yeah he or she have the instinct he was
just so
yeah the instinct and his speed he was
the first guy in the team
so the way he could just like guinness
rock dennis rodman rebounding
yeah you know dennis rodman is right
yeah but i mean it's the
scenario's a little bit different
because it's it's not like they're like
hey
we need to call the rebounder you know
dennis rodman i was just playing right
you seem saying but
this guy hey they're about to kick a
field goal hey freaking what the heck
was the name matt
oh man they're going to be mad at me for
now so this guy had good
instincts to get that hand on the ball
speed instincts
you know what's weird about this is he
must have been really good to
actually be identified as that guy yup
he totally was he was famous
for that so it was like that the team
was like kind of known for that like hey
buckle up when we kick field goals or
punts like this guy is coming
so there was time they got to the point
where they would stack that side
wherever he was
which is dangerous to do because you
open up the other side for other guys
but
bro it's that important that's how good
that's how good this specialized
um skill he had developed you know
there's something to be said about this
concept and
specializing and focusing on something
um i was watching the thing about wayne
gretzky
and when he was like he would sit there
and watch hockey games as a kid
and while he was watching the hockey
game he would trace the puck
like with a pen on the on the on like a
piece of paper
like he'd draw a hockey rink and then he
would sit there and trace where the puck
went where to go the whole time
and then when the game was over three
periods later he would look at the
where his marks were on this piece of
paper and start to think that's where
the puck is
this is where the puck is most the time
this is where i need to be yeah
and same with dennis rodman he would
know where different shooters on his
team would kind of spin they put on the
ball
and he'd be able to assess where that
ball was going to go where's the highest
chance of that happening that's what he
focused on
so if you can do that with a team and
you can get a team
focused on a particular item they're
going to excel at it it's a good concept